When troubleshooting a knitting machine,
the first question to ask is,
how is your sponge bar?
A flat sponge bar can be the culprit
that causes a myriad of problems.
It doesn't matter how old your machine is
or how much it's been used,
the sponge material deteriorates and it
can no longer do the job
of holding the needles in place.
On an LK150, it's often hard
to determine if the sponge is flat.
My machine was close to 10 years old,
and I was really surprised
at the condition of the sponge.
The needles didn't seem to be loose,
but the machine just wasn't knitting well.
Lesson learned: change your sponge
bar before you start to struggle.
Start by removing the carriage
and the tension mast.
Remove the clamps so you
can turn the bed over.
And remove each of your needles.
Close the latch and pick up
the by the needle butt and pull it back.
It should slip out pretty easily.
For more details about removing
and replacing needles,
see the video at
knititnow.Com/lk150needle.
Once all the needles are out of the needle
bed, you may want
to take time to clean it.
It's just plastic, so don't use any harsh
chemicals or cleaners
that might leave a residue.
Just a clean paint brush
may be all you need.
Turn the carriage over
and remove the old sponge.
Position the new sponge
with the ribbon facing up.
The needles will ride on this ribbon.
We'll replace the needles
by threading them over the sponge.
From the top of the bed, close
the needle latch and push the hook down.
use your fingers of your opposite
hand to guide the hook down.
Then push the back of the needle
down to thread it over the sponge.
Use your finger underneath
to guide it back into the slot.
Do this for all 150 needles.
Take it slow and don't be
afraid of bending the needles.
Use enough pressure to guide the needle
down and over the sponge and then back up
in the track towards the front of the bed.
Replace each of the needles.
The LK150 originally had gray and pink
rollers every 10 needles to help you keep
track and position your knitting without
having to count needles every time.
Once you get a new sponge bar in place,
you'll be amazed at how
well your machine knits.